It was in the morning after a night raid.
I just found it.
Like I was meant to.
I promised myself that if I made it out,...
...I would find that girl and thank her for saving my life.
I'm Beth.
Logan.
What brings you to Hampton?
It's kind of a long story.
There's a man here who came to apply for the job and I can't get rid of him.
How did you get him to leave?
I gave him the job.
You don't know anything about him.
Neither do you.
Who's that?
That's just somebody that nana hired.
Good night, all!
Do you like jambalaya?
Ben, I'm sure that Logan already has plans.
I can't remember the last time I had a plan.
Well, that's as clean as it will ever be.
You think I don't know what's going on around here?
You don't have a say anymore.
It's just a casual beer between coworkers.
It's not a date.
There's something that I've been meaning to tell you.
I'm sorry, I can't find the right words.
Hey, that's my son in there too, you know.
Let go of my arm.
You should do what she says.
You don't know what I'm dealing with.
I do know that you deserve better than this.
You stay the hell out of my life.
You should be kissed every day, every hour, every minute.
Where did you get this?
Your boy Logan had it.
I should have told you.
I tried. I didn't know how.
He just shows up here with something so personal?
It just doesn't smell right to me.
I think he was meant to find that photo.
I think it can happen for a reason.
How do you explain something that you can't even understand yourself?
Why did you come here?
To find you.